Central Banking is definitely a scam
it's just a pyramid scheme those that
can print money are able to steal from
those who cannot print money it's a form
of legal plunder you're stealing from
the poor and giving to the rich a lot of
the stolen purchasing power is used to
fund Warfare that typically fund both
sides of the conflicts because you can't
lose that way which obviously drives the
scale scope and severity of warfare
there's a good argument to be made that
neither World War One or World War II
would have been possible at the to the
scope that they were possible without
Central Banking we're always taught
these kind of moral Crusades why the
United States went to war it's never
actually about that governments are
businesses they're trying to tax people
they go to war occasionally with each
other purpose of the war is so that they
can expand their Dominion expand their
tax base capture and tax more people
these are just businesses that are
competing with each other but the
business they're in is human coercion
compulsion and violence so when they
compete what does that look like looks
like Warfare